it seems that almost every movie gets a
trilogy these days
truth is though a number of hugely
popular movies each followed up by
sequels have yet to see a third
installment join the franchise
and likely never will these are the
trilogies that will
never be completed bringing a
hilariously gruesome
reverence to the world of superheroes
long before deadpool made his silver
screen debut
no we don't count x-men origins
wolverine
and neither should you director matthew
vaughn's adaptation
of writer mark miller and artist john
romita jr's kick-ass was a
hit with critics and audiences alike
earning 48 million
domestically and 97 million dollars
worldwide universal wisely played it
safe only spending 28 million dollars on
the sequel but made a few critical
errors in the meantime
the first being that it was released in
2013 a full
five years after the original the second
was that directing duties were given to
jeff wadlow as vaughn was occupied with
x-men first class in 2011
and kingsman the secret service in 2014.
critics
ko'd kick ass 2 with a 32 tomato meter
rating
a significant drop on the first movie
and it earned just 28 million
domestically and 63 million dollars
worldwide while vaughn revealed his
hopes of directing both a prequel and a
sequel in 2015
he eventually stuck to the kingsman
series instead given kick ass 2's
diminishing returns and the several
years that have passed it's
probably fair to say that kick-ass and
company won't be making a return anytime
soon
before zack snyder's dawn of the dead
made bank and
amc's the walking dead made history
danny boyle's 2002 hit 28 days later was
the little undead flick that could
critics lauded the movie upon its
release and audiences were generous too
delivering a 45 million domestic and 82
million dollar worldwide take against a
measly 8 million
budget profits like that invariably
spell a sequel
but it would be four years before 28
weeks later
arrived in theaters while boyle passed
directorial duties onto juan carlos
president dio for the sequel
it still managed to garner a relatively
warm critical reception
alas audiences were less enthused as the
15 million dollar budgeted sequel earned
28 million dollars domestic and 64
million dollars worldwide that's
still highly profitable but it was also
a 22
drop from the first film despite costing
twice as much
even though the numbers were trending
downwards boyle later told mtv there
were a few ideas swirling about for a
third film
though screenwriter alex garland said
copyright issues with the rights holders
to the original film were holding them
back
however in 2019 boyle told the
independent that
somebody had come up with a wonderful
idea for a third film
nobody said a word about it since
however and for now it seems like the 28
days trilogy
is very much dead and buried with a
combined
1.2 billion dollars domestic and 2.29
billion dollars worldwide box office
across all his movies
quinton tarantino can pretty much call
his own shots
with that's a bingo
still one of his hardest sells was kill
bill a kung fu spaghetti western revenge
thriller mishmash
that was originally meant to be one four
hour film but
was wisely split into two releases both
kill bill volume 1
and kill bill volume 2 were hits with
the critics and
both made a decent amount at the box
office although volume 2 saw a 14
drop on the first movie's takings while
the kill bill films were
modest financial successes tarantino
went over budget and over schedule on
the movies forcing him to cut a
climactic beachside battle between the
bride and bill
and eventually having to miss the cannes
film festival he revealed plans for
volume
3 in 2004 suggesting it would follow
vernita green's daughter as she sought
revenge against the bride
with the hope being that tarantino would
begin filming 15 years
later while 15 years seemed like an
impossibly long time
then 2019 came and went with no volume
three and
tarantino conceded in 2012 that a third
film was
probably not happening probably not
seemed to turn
into definitely not when uma thurman
called tarantino out for a stunt that
nearly killed her during filming on the
first two
they have apparently buried the hatchet
since however and now tarantino says
volume 3 is
definitely in the cards believe it when
you see it
chinatown brilliantly mixed the film
noir genre of the 1940s with the new
hollywood aesthetic of the 1970s and
quickly became one of the definitive
films of the latter decade
while its 29 million box office didn't
break any records in 1974
the movie's 11 oscar nominations and one
win at the 1975 academy awards
cemented its sterling reputation while
chinatown is remembered as an all-time
great today however its 1990 sequel has
been
practically forgotten jack nicholson
returned his private eye jj jake giddez
in the two jakes
also stepping in for roman polanski's
director for pretty
obvious reasons the two jakes did all
right with the critics though it didn't
blow anyone out of the water and its
box office performance was truly
atrocious earning just 10
million dollars nicholson told mtv in
2007 that a third film titled guis vs
giddis would have been set in 1968
following jake as he goes through a
divorce given nicholson effectively
retired in 2010 however it seems that
this pulp detective take on kramer vs
kramer will probably never see the light
of day
forget it jake it's chinatown
escape from new york introduced one of
the most iconic
characters ever conceived in the
eyepatch wearing
smack-talking snake pliskin played with
a rebellious swagger
by kurt russell we'd make one hell of a
team snake
the name's pliskin while the film made a
profitable 25 million dollars worldwide
on a six million dollar budget in 1981
it wasn't the kind of breakaway
blockbuster that demanded
an immediate sequel carpenter and
russell focused on other projects for
the rest of the 1980s including their
equally beloved collaboration big
trouble in little china
meanwhile escape from new york's
reputation continued to grow
so in 1996 the duo returned for escape
from la
releasing a sequel to a cult hit 15
years after the original was a risky bet
especially with a 50 million dollar
budget twice what the original film
even made unfortunately escape from la
face
planted with critics and bombed with
crowds earning just 25 million dollars
worldwide
much less than the first movie after
inflation is taken into account and with
10 times the production budget to boot
while an escape from sequel wasn't going
to theaters
there were plans for a tv series in the
early 2000s although they
never amounted to anything a remake was
also announced in 2015 with robert
rodriguez set to direct though the movie
screenwriter has more recently said that
the project is still
in development everyone knows that if
you want to add prestige to your young
adult movie franchise you simply turn
the final film into a two-parter
for a while everyone seemed to be
getting on board with the trend from
harry potter to twilight to the hunger
games
of course this is probably down to the
fact that it's an incredibly easy way to
make money
especially when you film both parts at
once and surely nobody would be foolish
enough to only film part one of a
two-parter
right enter the divergent series the
first movie managed 276 million dollars
worldwide on an 85 million dollar budget
while the second
made 295 million dollars against a 110
million dollar budget
though its domestic opening weekend and
box office were smaller than the first
that should have been a clue but lion's
gate still went full steam ahead on the
series two-part conclusion
this wasn't a great move the divergent
series
allegiant tanked with 66 million
domestic and just 172 million dollars
worldwide
it was decided that spending the money
to properly conclude the trilogy would
be a waste
so the final installment was announced
as a tv movie instead
before being abruptly canceled still
you've got to give lionsgate credit for
releasing the first ever
two and a half film trilogy
the wayne's world franchise is the most
successful snl film series
ever with both movies earning 169
million dollars domestically and
million dollars worldwide bringing in
that much bacon
usually spells more sequels but instead
we wound up with mediocre snl spin-offs
such as
superstar and the ladies man so what
gives
well for one wayne's world 2 absolutely
plummeted at the box office
earning 136 million dollars less in 1993
than wayne's world
a terrifying 76 drop in earnings
and while paramount may have still been
willing to produce wayne's world 3
it sounds like the creative team just
wasn't interested mike myers left snl in
1995 and went on to star in the hugely
successful austin powers in shrek
franchises
layers dana carvey meanwhile starred in
his own
short-lived tv show the dana carvey show
starting in 1996.
in 1993 entertainment weekly had
reported that the ego swelling success
of wayne's world is taking its toll on
the relationship
between myers and carvey which started
when myers wrote a draft of wayne's
world 2 that included plenty of wayne
but
not a lot of garth couple that with
carvey's medical issues and
it's no surprise the world never got to
see wayne's world 3.
still the duo at least reunited for an
uber eats commercial during super bowl
55 which
is probably as close to a third film as
we'll ever get
when it comes to box office bank ability
denzel washington
is the king of hollywood in the gritty
equalizer series washington plays robert
mccall a former marine
who comes out of self-imposed retirement
to take on russian mobsters
the equalizer and the equalizer 2 earned
similarly impressive numbers at the box
office though the sequel cost
29 percent more than its predecessors as
such
sony pictures may have been cautious
about spending more on a hypothetical
equalizer 3
and potentially earning less worse still
denzel washington doesn't seem
interested in franchises in general in
fact
equalizer 2 was his first and thus far
only sequel one person who is interested
however is director antoine fuqua who
told the hollywood reporter in 2018
personally i'd love for it to happen it
would be great to do it again with
denzel
i'm looking forward to the equalizer 3
if that happens
but it hasn't and it doesn't look like
it will at least not on the big screen
cbs recently rebooted the series on
which the movies were based premiering
the show right after super bowl 55 on
february 7th 2021
in this iteration robert mccall is now
robin mccall with queen latifah stepping
in for denzel washington because
if you don't have the king you get the
queen instead
you may not know this but there are
actually two adam sandlers
one is the gifted actor of punch drunk
love and uncut gems
the other is well adam sandler alas
most of sandler's 5.5 billion dollars in
worldwide grosses have come from his
comedy work including the incredibly
successful grown-up series
the first grown-ups earned 272 million
dollars worldwide in 2010
and grownups 2 made 247 million dollars
in 2013
making grownups sandler's highest
grossing franchise
besides hotel transylvania obviously
even with the grown-ups movies all-star
casts ballooning the budgets up to 70 to
80 million dollars
they were incredibly profitable but the
franchise seems to have stalled
maria bello told flickering myth in 2016
that she loved to come back saying
boy it's fun to work with those guys on
january 6
2020 sandler fanatic and comedy writer
producer tom sharpling
even posted his unsanctioned script on
twitter writing
in april 2019 i wrote a script for
grownups 3.
i was not asked to write it it is the
best thing i will ever do in my life
professional or otherwise the script was
a meta
making of grown-ups in which the various
cast members are slowly killed off
predictably it went viral and equally
predictably
it also went nowhere with sandler busy
making more hotel transylvania movies
a host of netflix productions and a
number of more serious films it's
probably fair to say that this comedy
megastar has grown out of grownups
video game movies are generally
synonymous with the word awful but
for one brief moment it looked like the
mortal kombat series would break the
curse
and yes obviously 1995's mortal kombat
is still
bad but it's at least bad in a fun kind
of way
it also made a lot of money earning 122
million dollars worldwide on a 20
million dollar budget
the studio rushed a sequel which never
turns out well and despite its 30
million
budget mortal kombat annihilation ended
up looking like a sci-fi original
its two percent tomato meter score is
the second worst in video game movie
history
while the 51 million dollars worldwide
was a horrible 58
drop in takings now there's a franchise
fatality for you
flawless victory new line cinema had
been banking on at least
three mortal combat films however and
signed robin shu who played liu kang
to a three picture deal annihilation
annihilated any chance of that happening
but a third film
reportedly titled mortal kombat
devastation was apparently supposed to
happen
the movie spent more than a decade in
development hell before warner brothers
purchased midway games which owned
mortal kombat for
33 million dollars rather than throw
good money after bad
warner brothers relaunched the series
with an r rated reboot in 2021
jim carrey had pretty much the best year
ever in 1994
starring in back to back to back hits
ace ventura pet detective
the mask and dumb and dumber the mask
was the biggest hit of the bunch
by far earning 351 million dollars at
the box office
incredible numbers for an ultra violent
sealist character from dark force comics
despite the masks insane profitability
the only sequel was 2005's
horrible misfire son of the mask which
tanked with 59 million
on a 100 million budget
[Music]
carrie wisely sat that one out an
unsurprising choice giving his
long-standing distaste for sequels
however it sounds like the star may be
open to putting back on the mask as he
told comicbooknews.com in 2020
it would depend on a filmmaker i don't
want to just do it
but i would only do it if it was some
crazy visionary filmmaker
so granted carrie sounds reluctant about
the whole deal but there were rumors in
2020 that warner
brothers was considering both a
female-led reboot more in line with the
darker comic
and two new mask movies starring carrie
since then there haven't been any
updates on this potential franchise
and until carrie warms to the idea it's
doubtful
there ever will be both basic instinct
movies drew in
a bunch of money at the box office with
the first one earning 117 million
dollars domestically and 352 million
dollars worldwide in 1992 despite its
mediocre critical reception
and while strike while the irons haunt
may not be a
basic human instinct it is hollywood's
mantra making it all the more surprising
that it took
14 years for basic instinct 2 to arrive
on screens
michael douglas was out this time but
sharon stone returned as the psychotic
novelist catherine trammell
while the first movie made stone a star
however the sequel
probably killed any chance of her
headlining a film again
it tanked with the critics and did
nothing for audiences either bringing in
35 million
box office on a 70 million dollar budget
you'd think that have killed the
franchise stone
dead but according to a 2006 empire
online article
stone was optimistic about a sequel and
she even hopes to direct
she said there's a script for the next
part of the story but i would like to
direct it rather than star in it
according to a 2013 huffpost article
stone has changed her mind about not
starring in the film and is still
eager to give tremel closure in crank
jason statham has to keep his adrenaline
going to stay alive
by any means necessary in crank 2 high
voltage
statham's heart is replaced with a
battery that needs constant jolts of
electricity
what would have happened in crank 3
sadly
we'll never know crank cost 12 million
dollars and made 43 million dollars
worldwide
q sql crank 2 high voltage cost 20
million dollars and made 35 million
dollars worldwide
so game over right well co-director mark
neville dean was confident the franchise
would keep going telling empire online
in 2011
crank 3 is going to happen the studios
are really excited about it
it's just all about timing four years
later statham told we got this covered
i'd love to do it neville dean and
co-creator brian taylor have to get
their heads together and if they want to
do it then there's a conversation
in 2018 taylor told the movie crypt
podcast that given crank 2's
disappointing box office
it's got to be a great idea something
insane crank 3 should be as
exponentially more
dup than crank 2 as crank 2 was with
crank 1.
the blues brothers was one of the best
comedies of its
era and blues brothers 2000 was among
the worst snl movies ever
nearly 20 years separated these two
movies but given the sequel lacked john
belushi or
you know any redeeming value it
absolutely tanked earning just 14
million dollars at the box office
about 17 years later commemorating the
original's 35th anniversary dan
aykroyd told cbs news that if universal
ever wanted to make a third film
i have a story of course but it involves
handing it off to a younger generation
acroid was even more emphatic in a 2015
interview with the daily mail
telling the outlet that the blues
brothers will return for a dvd
and video on demand special with jim
belushi stepping in for his late brother
aykroyd said the focus will be on
ellwood helping find a new generation
to lead the blues and that idea is
handing down to a new generation
finding a pair of girls who are 20 21
and one to be the blues sisters
in a 2018 interview with et canada
aykroyd even revealed his dreamcast for
this sequel saying
i like lupita nyong'o and i like taylor
swift
whether the blues sisters ever comes to
pass however is pretty much
anybody's guess check out one of our
newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movie series are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one